why don't we go to something like a
little bit more lighter uh with what
Hillary had to say here on The View okay
motivational rap if he can play this uh
uh when she speaks it's just the world
gets Cal her voice is like a soothing by
the way which voice can you go with for
four years rank it Hillary Clinton
camalo or Nikki Haley you have to listen
one of those three voices could be the
president that you have to listen to for
four years is this the the old Mary F
kill game I'm just curious like pick
which one is the least to the one that
you're okay with I'll go Haley Hillary
kamla I cannot no he said least least
Hillary oh no no no no no no I then I go
the other way kamla Hillary haly I can't
do kamla I just can't oh my God this is
wait oh my God this is so I do Haley
Hillary KLA in that order like that
what's that oh my God it's like all
horrible okay I would I would rather die
than listen to Hillary Clinton's voice
then it be kamala's cackle and then
Nikki Haley third oh my God just you
saying that really bother sounds like a
for actually Haley doesn't have a
you what you say you're scum you scum
scum of the earth here let's listen to a
pleasant voice go ahead Rob people would
get legitimately elected no and then
they would try to do away with elections
and do away with opposition and do away
with a free press and you could see it
in countries where well Hitler was duly
elected right right and so all of a
sudden somebody with those Tendencies
the dictatorial authoritarian Tendencies
would be like okay we're going to shut
this down we're going to throw these
people in jail and and they didn't
usually Telegraph that Trump is telling
us what He intends to do wow and people
believe her is it over well he looked at
her didn't he look at her wait a minute
didn't he look at her to debate and say
because you'd be in jail oh my God that
was hands down that was one of the best
moments in all of debates hands but like
I know Reagan had his moments when but
that when Donald Trump when she was like
you know it's awfully good that with not
somebody like with the temperament of
Donald Trump is in president of United
States oh can you please hear this Pat
please can we hear it awfully good that
someone with the temperament of Donald
Trump is not in charge of the law in our
country because you'd be in
jail and he turns
around that was the moment where his
fate was sealed that they were going to
throw his ass in jail 100% just know
that actually a good point yeah that was
it that was it just when you start
saying things like that to establishment
Hillary Clinton believe me they're going
to start digging up some things by the
way as far as the the KLA thing look
where she
Hillary at least I would say she's smart
now is she Mach of valiant is she
Sinister is she up to no good she's not
an idiot she's a triple word she Kamala
is not smart enough to even be
Machiavellian space she slept her way to
the top in California from what I hear
here Ask Judge Joe Brown I that's what
we've heard about he's actually the meme
right the guy with the big the black bar
isn't he the
meme go ahead oh my
gosh are we down on this question
everybody's by the way how many text
message did you get like super important
message you have to see this open it up
now and you open it up that black dude
with the and it's like oh man my mom my
mom sending me stuff I'm like Mom what's
your problem she's like it's funny open
email your mom s you that I I don't know
what I I don't know what I can add to
that nothing about three
inches we were just talking about KLA
Hillary I I think about I I think it's
so you either have the unbearable or the
makavelian or you get the Warhawk and so
I I go with the Warhawk you know you
want the
Warhawk well
between Haley and and Clinton and Camala
yeah you said the least you wanted I you
know who knows who knows what's going to
happen with uh what is by the was
Hillary promoting a book Rob when she
was on what was she
promoting was she promoting a
documentary of uh what was that I'm not
sure let me take a look I'll find out
okay I thought it was like a documentary
of how Jan Maxwell got killed she oh
she's actually alive I'm sorry mistake
it was
F she's and a fun fact P she's doing 20
years they just had an article that
she's complaining about moldy food but
isn't it crazy though Epstein arrested
you know suicided and and she's in jail
forever but what about all the clients
are they not going to care about going
after all these clients that were using
all these underage people that they were
having sex with are we not going to go
after that list what are you talking
that's Whitney web no what I'm saying is
Pat so they caught the sex trafficking
King guy the you know Epstein he's gone
right they arrested her what about all
the people that were their clients are
not are they're not going to go after
the the black book the book or I mean
there's a list every that was there
flight logs yeah well are we not going
to go after the people that use their
services who's we what do you mean
America the government I mean I'm just
waiting like where the arrests I know
the prince what was his name was it
Albert Prince William Prince Will who's
the one that got in trouble with prin
Andrew prince Andrew that's yeah and the
queen was like you know what his
punishment was Andy you know what his
punishment was for for being with the
underage girl you're losing your Royal
privileges people aren't going to call
you whatever in public so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here